Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, we're going to continue
the discussion of cardiovascular
physiology today.
In particular,
pay attention to the heart and
its role in creating the
pressure that moves blood
throughout the circulatory
system.
I'm going to take a step back
and let's review what we talked
about at the end,
and then we'll get into the new
material for today.
The heart is an element of
the circulatory system.
It's a critical element,
obviously and it--you can show
it, as in this picture,
in the center of the
circulatory system where its
role is to supply the pressure
drop that moves blood through
what's called the systemic
circulation,
or the circulation to all of
the tissues in the body,
the circulation of oxygen rich
blood to all the tissues in the
body flowing from the aorta,
through arteries,
through arterioles,
capillaries,
collecting venules back to
veins,
back to the heart.
The second circulatory system,
the pulmonary circulatory
system, which sends
de-oxygenated,
or oxygen-poor blood,
through the lungs,
through the pulmonary artery,
arterioles,
capillaries,
veins, back through the
pulmonary vein to the left side
of the heart.
One can think about the heart
as two functioning units that
are coupled in some way.
We're going to see that they're
coupled in almost every way.
They're coupled because the
output from one side of the
heart is the input to the other
side.
The output from the left side
of the heart goes through this
circuit and then back to the
right side.
The output from the right side
goes through this circuit and
then back to the left side,
and so they're coupled.
They're also coupled because
it's one organ,
and so when this organ performs
its function which is
contraction,
these things are happening
simultaneously because it's one
individual organ that's
accomplishing it.
We talked briefly about the
anatomy of the heart and I
brought a model of the heart
here,
larger than actual size but
with an--so it's not like a real
heart in that way.
It's also not like a real heart
because you can open it up and
take a look inside.
I'm going to bring this to
section if you want to look at
it or you can come up and look
at it after class.
To illustrate some of the
features that are shown in this
cartoon, that there's a
difference in the muscular
walls.
That the left side of the heart
has a thicker muscle than the
right side of the heart and that
there are vessels on the surface
of the heart,
so vessels that come off of the
aorta, for example,
the red vessels here that serve
the myocardium or the surface of
the heart and supply it with
oxygen.
That the right and left side of
the heart is divided into two
chambers.
On the left side there's the
left ventricle,
and the left atrium above it,
right ventricle,
right atrium above it.
If we look inside there are
valves that guard the entrances
between these compartments.
There's a valve in going from
the right atrium to the right
ventricle--I'm just going to put
all the names up on the--there's
a valve in going from the right
atrium to the right ventricle
and that's called the tricuspid
valve.
There's a valve in going from
the right ventricle into the
pulmonary artery and that's
called the pulmonary valve.
You can't see it very well here
but it's up here.
There's a valve in going from
the left atrium into the left
ventricle and that's call the
mitral valve,
and a valve in going from the
left atrium into the aorta and
that's called the aortic valve.
There's four valves that are
important and they guard the
entrances.
One of the key things we're
going to talk about today is the
function of these valves in
producing a flow.
You know that the heart
functions, it creates pressure
by beating, by contracting,
it beats.
How is pressure generated when
that happens?
You know that blood moves,
blood flows because of a
pressure drop.
We talked last time about the
relationship between a pressure
drop and a flow.
Whenever there's a pressure
drop if there is the possibility
of flow, there's some resistance
to that flow,
and a certain amount of flow is
created which depends on the
resistance.
Resistance goes up;
flow goes down for a fixed
pressure drop.
Resistance goes down;
flow goes up for a fixed
pressure drop.
The pressure drop is what
creates the flow.
You also know that pressure
varies with volume.
If I have a container that
contains a liquid or a gas and I
compress the container the
pressure goes up inside.
Why is that?
Why does pressure go up as
volume goes down?
The most simple system to think
about is an ideal gas.
Ideal gas: PV = nRT;
an ideal gas pressure times the
volume = nRT.
If temperature,
the gas constant,
and the number of molecules are
constant, then when pressure
goes up volume has to go down;
volume goes down,
pressure goes up.
Why is that?
What's happening inside?
Brian?Student:
Normal activity can delay
[inaudible].Professor
Mark Saltzman: Right,
exactly.
The molecules are closer
together, they're closer to the
walls, the force of pressure is
created by collisions of the
molecules with the walls.
This is a very simple
description obviously,
but you can imagine as the
volume goes down and the
pressure goes up,
more molecules bouncing against
the walls and creating pressure.
Same thing happens in a liquid;
only in a liquid the change is
not so dramatic as in an ideal
gas.
In general, liquids are
considered to be incompressible.
You're not pushing their
molecules closer together so
much because it's a condensed
fluid, but pressure still varies
with volume in the same way.
You can't describe it by this
equation anymore because this
only applies for ideal gases,
but the same thing is true that
when volume goes down--the
volume and the number of
molecules is fixed--then the
pressure goes up.
Another way of thinking
about it that is far less
scientific is--because
everybody's seen Star Wars,
not the later imitation Star
Wars but the first one where
Luke Skywalker gets trapped with
somebody.
I forget even--in this room,
in this garbage dump,
and the walls start coming in.
As the walls start coming in,
he gets more and more urgent
about getting out.
His pressure is going up as the
volume is going down and the
pressure to get out gets higher
and higher, it's the same kind
of thing here.
Volume is decreasing,
pressure goes up.
When the heart beats or
contracts it decreases the
volume of these chambers.
When the muscle contracts it
decreases the volume of the
chambers inside;
the volume of the chambers goes
down and there is blood inside
and that blood gets squeezed as
the pressure--as the volume goes
down the pressure goes up.
That's how pressure is
generated.
Why do you need valves?
Why are valves important in the
function of the heart?
I already alluded to the fact
that your heart cannot function
properly without valves that are
acting correctly.
Why do you need a valve?
Well, imagine that you had a
simpler system than your heart.
You had a balloon that was
attached to a garden hose and
the whole thing was filled with
water.
If I decrease the volume of the
balloon, the pressure in the
balloon goes up and water goes
out the garden hose;
if I decrease the volume.
What if I expand it again?
Well, then the pressure goes
down inside the garden hose and
all the water gets sucked back
in.
You can imagine if you had a
water hose that--or a garden
hose that was hooked up to a
reservoir and a balloon on one
end,
and you inflated it,
and deflated it,
inflated it,
you'd be pushing water out and
pulling it in and it would go
back and forth in this way.
If you're increasing and
decreasing the volume by the
same amount you'd be pushing out
a volume of water and pulling it
back in.
Now that's a kind of a flow
but it's not the continuous one
directional kind of flow that we
have in our circulatory systems.
That would be a--you could
imagine a circulatory system
that's based on that,
where you have a heart that
pushes blood out and then sucks
it back in, and then pushes it
out and sucks it back in,
but that's not the way that the
human heart functions.
In order to get blood flowing
in one direction you push the
blood out, you close a gate,
and then when you're
re-inflating the heart the blood
can't come back.
The function of these valves is
to prevent that reverse flow of
blood back into the heart when
it's relaxing or increasing its
volume.
The basic function of the heart
is to contract,
decrease its volume,
increase the pressure,
blood goes out,
valve closes preventing blood
from coming back into the
chamber that just ejected the
blood.
Then, that chamber relaxes and
goes back to its original
volume.
That's the basic function of
the heart and we're going to
spend the rest of the time
talking about the details of how
that happens.
It's clear why valves are a
necessary part of that cycle.
Pressure varies throughout
the circulatory system.
If pressure is indeed generated
in the heart,
as I've said,
then you would expect the
highest pressures to be in the
regions that are closest to the
heart.
If I measured pressure in the
aorta, and we talked about this
last time, you would find that
pressure varies with time.
Because pressure is going up
and down in the heart,
that oscillation in pressure
with heartbeat gets transmitted
into the aorta as well and we'll
talk in a minute about why that
happens.
If you looked over time an
average pressure in the aorta
would be somewhere between 120
and 80 mmHg, so let's just call
it 90 here.
The pressure in the aorta is 90.
If you think about the whole
circuit, this blood has to flow
from the aorta,
through the systemic
circulation and back into the
right atrium.
In the right atrium it's at the
end of its journey and that
pressure there is approximately
0.
The pressure drop that's
driving blood through the
systemic circulatory system is
ΔP of 90-0.
The pressure that's generated
here gets used completely in
driving the flow around.
If I looked at intermediate
positions I'd find that if I
looked in the arterioles the
pressure is about 35 mmHg,
so the pressure dropped from
here to here is 55 mmHg.
The pressure drop from the
arterioles to the venules is
about 20 mmHg,
and from the venules back to
the right atrium is 15-0 or 15
mmHg.
Pressure drops throughout
the circulatory system.
If you look on the pulmonary
side, you'll find the same
phenomenon, but in general,
the pressures are lower.
The pressure in the pulmonary
artery is only about 15 mmHg,
dropping to about 6 mmHg in the
capillaries where oxygen
exchange occurs,
dropping back to 0 when you get
to the left atrium.
What does that tell you about
the pulmonary circulation
compared to the systemic
circulation?
The pressure drop across the
systemic circulation is 90 mmHg,
across the pulmonary
circulation is 15 mmHg,
what does that tell you about
the pulmonary circulation in
comparison to the systemic
circulation?
Justin?Student: The
flow isn't as
fast.Professor Mark
Saltzman: Flow is not as
fast.
Is that true?
What do you think?
What's the flow through the
aorta?
It's 5L/min and I think that
was a good answer.
The flow might be not as fast
because there's not as much of a
pressure drop,
but we know because this is an
interconnected system,
that the flow is actually
5L/min at every cross--every
location in the circulatory
system.
It's a continuous circuit,
so the flow has to be the same
everywhere.
Justin's answer was one
possibility and it's a good one,
but that doesn't work in this
connected kind of a system.
Then if the flow is the same
what has to be different?
Student: [Inaudible]
Professor Mark Saltzman:
I'm sorry,
Naomi.Student: It's
pulse generated,
it's not as fast and doesn't
have to go to the rest of the
body.Professor Mark
Saltzman: It doesn't have to
go to the rest of the body,
so it doesn't have to generate
as much pressure.
You're on the right track,
so what does that tell you in
terms of the numbers you were
dealing with on your homework?
Which system has a higher
resistance?
The systemic system has a
higher resistance because it
takes a higher pressure drop in
order to create the same flow.
The systemic circulation has a
higher resistance than the
pulmonary circulation--high
resistance, high pressure
circuit;
low resistance,
low pressure circuit.
There's consequences of
that.
It sort of makes sense now that
you've done your homework
problem for this week that the
resistance through the pulmonary
system would be less because
it--you don't have so far too
travel.
The blood doesn't have so far
to travel so the length is much
less, you don't have to push the
blood as far,
it doesn't have to go up to
your head and down to your toes
and so less overall resistance.
Because it has less resistance
you don't need as much pressure
drop.
Because you don't need as much
pressure drop you don't need as
much muscle.
I don't need to generate as
high a pressure,
so the right side has less
muscle mass than the left side.
The reason for more muscle mass
on the left is to create the
higher pressure that's needed to
drive this high resistance
circuit.
This diagram shows you the
events in what's called the
cardiac cycle.
The cardiac cycle is this
rhythmic movement that we call a
heartbeat, and it goes through a
very systematic cycle.
It's a cycle,
so you could start and end it
anywhere.
We're going to start in this
region of the cycle that's
called late diastole,
and diastole is the relaxation
phase.
Diastole is the relaxation
phase;
systole is the contraction
phase.
In late diastole that's the
moment right before the beat
starts or the contraction
starts.
In late diastole,
look at the situation here,
there's blood flowing back into
the atria,
coming from the circulation
that's driven by the pressure
created by the last heartbeat.
There's some blood moving from
the atrium into the ventricle.
That's true because this valve,
the mitral valve is open;
the mitral valve is open so
blood is flowing back to the
left atrium and back into the
left ventricle.
The heart is relaxed;
it's passively flowing into the
heart.
At the beginning of
contraction--another word for
contraction is systole,
diastole/systole--now the heart
starts to contract,
but one region of the heart
starts to contract first.
The contraction occurs in an
orderly fashion,
it starts in the atria and it
moves to the ventricles,
first the atrium contract.
If you look at this they're not
very muscular,
they have muscles but they're
not anything like the ventricle.
You can think of it as a weaker
muscle than the ventricle is.
It contracts first and when it
contracts the volume decreases.
It increases the pressure
inside the atrium,
and more blood starts flowing
from the atrium into the
ventricle.
What happens?
This contraction decreases the
volume, increases the pressure,
increases the pressure drop
between the atrium and the
ventricle,
and more blood gets--flows into
the ventricle.
Now the contraction moves
to the ventricle.
The ventricle starts to
contract, and when it contracts
the pressure starts going up
inside.
When the pressure goes up
inside the mitral valve closes.
That's important because you
don't want blood to flow back
into the atrium,
and back into the pulmonary
vein.
The mitral valve closes and
this contraction starts in a
period called isovolumetric
contraction.
This isovolumetric contraction
means that both of the
entrances, both the entrance and
the exit into the ventricle are
closed.
The mitral valve is closed,
the aortic value is closed,
contraction is proceeding,
so the volume is trying to
decrease but it can't.
,The pressure goes up during
contraction to the point where
the aortic valve opens.
This is pressurized blood which
is ejected through the aorta,
flow through the aorta,
and then the aortic valve
closes again when diastole is
complete.
Just focus on what's
happening on the left side,
the right side is doing the
same thing but just at lower
pressures.
Systole begins,
atria contracts,
blood flows into the ventricle,
ventricle contracts,
both the doors are closed,
the valves are closed,
pressure gets higher.
Then, eventually the aortic
valve opens, and you get this
event called ventricular
ejection where a volume of blood
bursts out of the ventricle into
the aorta.
The aortic valve closes again
and the cycle repeats itself.
This is a schematic diagram to
show you sort of the sequence of
events, contraction and valve
activity that lead to the
forward surge of blood.
The amount of blood that is
ejected from the left ventricle
on each cycle is called the
ejection volume.
If you took the ejection volume
and multiplied it by the heart
rate you get the cardiac output.
The ejection volume or the
volume of blood that's ejected
from the ventricle on each beat
times the heart rate is equal to
the cardiac output (EV * HR =
CO).
You know this is
five--approximately at rest,
5L/min.
If you assume that your cardiac
output while you're sitting
there is 5L/min and you put your
finger on your pulse and measure
your heart rate,
then you could calculate
approximately how much blood is
being ejected from the ventricle
with each beat.
Let's think about that same
kind of thing in more detail
where we really track the
pressures because it turns out
that following the pressures and
thinking about what's happening
in the chambers and the valves
you can get a fairly complete
picture of the physics of how
cardiac ejection occurs.
This diagram is--it's in
the Power Points and--but it's a
little hard to see I think on
the projection so I redrew it
down here in color.
What it shows is pressure from
0 to 120 as a function of time
during the cardiac cycle.
I didn't write any time units
on here but this is time
progressing.
This shows you two beats of the
heart.
The most prominent thing that
you notice is the green line
here which shows pressure in the
ventricle.
Which ventricle am I showing?
How would you tell?
I said they're both roughly the
same, but how would you tell if
you this was the left or the
right ventricle?
The total pressure,
and the pressure is high so
this must be the left ventricle
because it's reaching about 90
mmHg,
the pressure you need to drive
the systemic circulation.
This is indeed the left
ventricle and it's the left
atrium.
You could have also noticed
this is the aorta I'm going to
show you here,
so if I'm showing the unit it
must be the left side of the
heart.
The first thing you notice
is this big bump in pressure;
this is the trace for the
ventricle.
If I had a pressure sensor in
the ventricle and I was
measuring how pressure changed
as a function of time,
I would measure what you see on
this green line here.
Pressure starts off fairly low
and then goes up to 120 mmHg,
and goes back down again,
up to 120 mmHg,
down again.
This is the trace for the
atrium on the bottom here.
You'll notice that the pressure
in the atrium doesn't go through
these big excursions that the
ventricle does.
That's because the atrium is
not a powerful pump.
It's not a powerful muscle,
and so it only generates a
little bit of pressure when it
contracts.
The role of the atrium is to
contract to basically fill up
the ventricle so that when the
ventricle goes through its
massive contraction,
it's as full of blood as it can
be.
The atrium gives a little
beat in order to push whatever
blood is in it into the
ventricle.
It doesn't have to go very far
so you don't need so much
pressure, and fill up the
ventricle so that when the
ventricle contracts you get as
much ejection of blood as
possible,
the biggest volume ejected
possible.
If I looked at the difference
in pressures between the atrium
and the ventricle,
at this point here,
and this point here where I'm
starting is late in diastole,
remember what was happening
late in diastole was that blood
is flowing from the left atrium
into the left ventricle and the
mitral valve is open.
That's what you see here,
the pressure is slightly higher
in the atrium than it is in the
ventricle.
If I looked at the pressure
drop at this point ΔP it's
higher in the atrium than it is
in the ventricle and blood is
naturally flowing that way.
That only happens if the mitral
valve is open and it is at this
point;
the mitral valve is open during
diastole.
The atrium contracts,
you see the little bump of
pressure created by the atrium
contraction, and then the
ventricle contracts.
This is the start of systole
right here, where the
contraction of the atrium starts
is the beginning of the
heartbeat.
What happens?
The atrium contracts,
pressure stays higher in atrium
than it is in the ventricle.
So, blood is flowing from the
atrium into the ventricle,
and then all of a sudden the
ventricle starts contracting.
The ventricle has a bigger
contraction, more muscle,
so it's going to generate more
pressure.
At some point very shortly
after it starts to contract,
the pressure in the ventricle
becomes higher than the pressure
in the atrium.
When the pressure in the
ventricle becomes higher than
the pressure in the atrium,
the valve between them,
the mitral valve,
closes.
It closes strictly due to the
fact--it closes for a number of
reasons but one of the reasons
it closes is because there's
more pressure here now then
there is here and it slams the
door shut.
It's a one way valve;
when pressure becomes higher in
the ventricle than the atrium,
the valve closes.
At this point here,
where the lines cross,
this is the mitral valve
closing.
What's happening at the
other--at the exit?
Well the aorta is this--the
pressure in the aorta is this
orange line here.
The pressure in the aorta is
high.
Why is the pressure in the
aorta high?
Because it was filled up with
blood from the last heartbeat,
it was--this blood was ejected
into the aorta at high pressure,
that pressure stays there from
the last heartbeat.
Now, why does it do that?
Because the aortic valve is
closed;
during diastole the aortic
valve is closed.
That means that the pressure
that was generated stays high in
the aorta, even as the ventricle
is relaxing.
The blood can't get sucked back
from the aorta into the
ventricle because at this point
the aortic valve is closed.
When the mitral valve closes,
the aortic valve is already
closed, that means the ventricle
is sealed off.
That's what I showed you in the
diagram here right after atrial
systole.
Both valves are closed and the
ventricle is contracting.
Because both valves are closed
and the ventricle is contracting
we have the Luke Skywalker
situation,
where pressure starts to rise
dramatically inside the closed
chamber.
Eventually that pressure is
going to rise enough that the
pressure in the ventricle
crosses over the pressure in the
aorta.
At this point what happens?
The aortic valve opens and
blood can be ejected from the
ventricle into the aorta.
Now, that's the only path for
the blood to go because the
mitral valve is still closed.
The mitral valve is still
closed because the pressure in
the ventricle is still much
higher than it is in the atrium.
What this diagram shows you is
a couple of different things.
It shows you pressure in each
of the chambers,
think about the chamber,
the atrium, the ventricle,
the aorta.
Depending on where one pressure
sits with respect to the other,
if the pressure in the
ventricle is higher than the
pressure in the aorta,
then the aortic valve is open.
If it's the other way the
aortic valve is closed,
and the same thing with the
ventricle and the atrium.
The aortic valve opens
here, contraction continues.
This is the active phase of
ejection, which is shown in the
diagram here,
mitral valve closed,
aortic valve open,
pressure high here,
pressure lower here.
So, blood is ejected from the
heart, the muscle eventually
starts to relax,
contraction is complete,
the ventricle starts relaxing.
When the ventricular pressure
passes through this point and
drops below the aortic pressure,
then the aortic valve closes.
When the ventricular
pressure--the ventricle
continues to relax,
eventually it falls even below
the pressure in the atrium,
and the mitral valve opens and
the ventricle begins refilling
for the next contraction.
Does this make sense?
This diagram--If you
understand this diagram then you
understand the biophysics of
pressure generation and flow
generation by the heart.
It's a little bit hard to grasp
all at once, but if you walk
through it in the way that I
showed you then I think you'll
begin to understand it.
Another way to understand it is
to look at this diagram.
I've shown it a little bit more
clearly here,
the mitral valve closing,
aortic valve opening,
aortic valve closing,
mitral valve reopening.
If you can follow the pressures
and keep this diagram in mind,
why those valves open at the
times they do makes sense.
The fact that they open in the
sequence they do allow the heart
to undergo a cyclic contraction
and relaxation which results in
a net forward flow of blood.
This shows just where the
active contraction of systole
and diastole fall on this curve.
Systole begins when the atrium
begins to contract,
atrium contracts,
ventricle contracts,
systole ends here,
and the ventricle starts to
relax at that point and that's
diastole.
Early diastole,
the ventricle is still
relaxing, late diastole
everything is fully relaxed and
prepared for the next heartbeat.
What's the time of this whole
sequence?
Well, how fast--what's a heart
rate?
60 to 70 beats per minute;
so this whole sequence here
takes about a second.
Athletes, it's well known,
training can decrease your
heart rate.
What does that tell you?
Do athletes need less blood
flow?
No, they need about the same
blood flow but they have a
higher ejection volume.
Their heart is operating very
efficiently;
ejecting more volume per beat
and so they need less beats to
supply the cardiac output.
There are other changes
that occur during training as
well, that's not the only thing,
but that's one thing that
certainly occurs.
As you become more
cardiovascular--as your
cardiovascular fitness increases
you can--what happens when you
start to exercise?
Two things happen when you
start to exercise.
One is your heart rate goes up,
the second is your heart starts
beating with more force,
so both the heart rate and the
ejection volume go up in order
to create more cardiac output.
A conditioned athlete will be
able to do both of those very
efficiently.
They can create a higher
cardiac output with less work
from the heart.
That's why with conditioning
and training,
you can start to be more--your
performance will be enhanced
even though your heart rate
might not go up as someone who
is out of condition.
This is just another
picture of the cardiac cycle
where now I've sort of combined
everything together.
You can see this pressure curve
here, the pressure curve for the
aorta, for the ventricle,
for the atrium,
and you can visually correlate
that with what's happening in
each event.
Late diastole,
all the muscles are relaxed and
blood is passively flowing back
into the left atrium and through
the mitral valve which is open
to the left ventricle.
When contraction begins,
first in the atrium,
blood is pumped into the
ventricle.
The role of atrial contraction
is roughly to fill up the
ventricle as much as possible.
When the ventricle starts to
contract, pressure in the
ventricle rises above pressure
in the atrium,
causing the mitral valve to
close.
The aortic valve is already
closed, so now you have a closed
chamber here.
This contraction is an
isovolumetric contraction,
fixed volume of blood trying to
increase--the heart is working
to try to decrease the volume,
it can't, so the pressure goes
up.
When the pressure goes up above
what it is in the aorta,
the aortic valve opens,
blood is ejected,
the muscle starts to relax,
and the aortic valve closes.
Now this is key;
if your aortic valve didn't
close what would happen here?
You'd pull in that blood that
you just ejected into the aorta,
you'd pull it back into the
ventricle.
A little bit does come back
because the valve doesn't close
immediately;
a little bit does come back but
not very much.
When physicians are
listening to your heart one of
the things they're listening for
is sounds that aren't normally
present in a functioning heart.
Those sounds often have to do
with valves that are not
functioning properly.
If during late systole,
right after systole is over,
if they hear a 'whoosh' of
blood when they shouldn't,
that might be because your
aortic valve isn't functioning
properly and blood is whooshing
back into the ventricle when it
shouldn't be.
Same thing with the mitral
valve, if they hear a noise at
this point in the cardiac cycle,
that might be a flow of blood
back from the ventricle into the
atrium when it shouldn't be
happening,
that might be because your
mitral valve is not functioning
properly.
That's what physicians are
listening for when they listen
to your chest during a physical
exam.
Wilma?Student: What
causes the pressure in the left
atrium to rise a little bit
after the mitral valve
closes?Professor Mark
Saltzman: Here?
So, what causes this little
blip of pressure here after the
mitral valve closes do you
think?
Well, it probably happens just
because you're getting this
massive contraction in the
ventricle that's right
underneath it.
There's some change in volume
here as well even though the
atrial contraction is almost
complete.
Tou're also getting sort of a
bystander effect from this very
large contraction down here and
so that is--follows very closely
the pressure rise in the
ventricle and is just a
byproduct of that.
Other questions?
What I want to talk
about--so that's the end of the
material that's covered on your
mid-term exam which is next
Thursday.
What I want to talk about next
week is--on Tuesday--is the
cardiac conduction system.
I think you can see now that
for this orderly sequence of
events to occur it has to be
regulated in some way.
The proper function of your
heart requires all these things
to occur in a very specific
sequence.
The atrium has to contract
before the ventricle and in
order for this logical
progression of pressures,
proper functioning of the
valves, etc.
Well, it's the cardiac
conduction system or this
specialized system that moves
electrical impulses through the
heart that is responsible for
coordinating the function of the
heart on the heartbeat.
The cardiac conduction system
is an electrical system where
impulses are carried through the
substance of the heart.
Now, heart tissue is muscular
tissue, it's also electrically
active tissue.
Each of the cells are capable
of undergoing an action
potential just like action
potentials in nerves.
The action potential in a
muscle cell is not strictly
informational like it is in the
nervous system.
An action potential was the way
that an electrical signal got
propagated from one end of the
nerve to the other.
In muscle cells electrical
signals get propagated from one
muscle cell to another,
but another thing happens.
This electrical signal also
activates the contraction
mechanism inside cells.
As they're passing the
electrical signal they're also
getting the message to contract.
Electrical activity in muscle
cells is linked to contraction
and so as this electrical
activity passes over the heart
in an orderly fashion,
because of the cardiac
conduction system,
as it passes in an orderly
fashion over the surface of the
heart,
as you'll see next time,
I'm showing it this way,
this is the way the electrical
signal passes from right atrium
down through left ventricle.
As it passes in that orderly
way the muscles are activated to
contract in an orderly way as
well,
I'd like you to review for next
time what we talked about in
terms of action potentials that
are in Chapter 6 because we're
going to talk about those in the
context of a heart for next
time.
Questions?
I'll see you this
afternoon.